revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 una nueva revista de prensa
Rosa Pérez mateu vamos a volver a
repasar la prensa internacional para
hablar por supuesto de uno de los temas
centrales en nuestra región ocurrió ayer
y fue este atentado fallido contra la
vicepresidenta de Argentina Cristina
Fernández recordemos que cuando ella
estaba digamos saliendo de un vehículo
afuera de su residencia en la ciudad de
Buenos Aires un sujeto le apuntó a la
cara le disparó pues este tiro no fue
detonado no pasó nada digamos contra la
vida de la vicepresidenta por supuesto
las autoridades actuaron este hombre ya
se encuentra detenido se estaba
manejando la hipótesis que es una de
origen brasileño de 35 años de edad Pero
por supuesto es una información que está
en desarrollo el presidente Alberto
Fernández también se pronunció declaró
hoy día viernes estamos ya a dos de
septiembre y dijo que se declaró como
día festivo para en apoyo a la
presidenta y que las personas que
querían salir a las calles para pues
respaldarla lo hicieran sin ningún
problema no con el trabajo efectivamente
Hola de nuevo Raúl y primero empecemos a
repasando la prensa Argentina no como
responde a esta conmoción conmoción es
la palabra que encontramos en todas las
portadas Y empezamos por Clarín que
titula noche dramática Y es que
recordemos que los hechos tuvieron lugar
sobre las 9 de la noche hora Argentina y
destaca esta esa fotografías que
muestran la secuencia de los hechos con
el pie de foto la llegada de Cristina
kirchner y momentos después ante su cara
la pistola semiautomática que no se
disparó Y todavía un poco la incógnita
sobre porque no se disparó porque estaba
cargada con cinco balas pero ninguna en
la recámara y el titular detienen como
decías a un brasileño que gatilló un
arma en la cabeza de Cristina tiene como
decías 35 años y antecedentes había
detenido en el 2021 por portar una
cuchillo y viene todavía no se sabe
entre otras incógnitas tampoco si actuó
solo en grupo qué motivaciones tenía
exactamente en todo caso Clarín también
destaca que estos hechos han
desencadenado una breve tregua en la
política Argentina ya que desde Mauricio
macri no toda la oposición se ha
solidarizado con la ex presidenta y
actual vicepresidenta vamos ahora con la
nación que también de nuevo titula
conmoción en todo el país un hombre
intentó dispararle a Cristina kirchner
en la cabeza y destaca un tiempo
incierto ante lo inconcebible y algunas
palabras del presidente Alberto
Fernández que tildó el hecho de El más
grave desde la vuelta a la democracia
dijo la paz social ha sido alterada no y
una cita muy contundente de Alberto
Fernández que declaró Cristina permanece
en vida porque por una razón todavía no
confirmada técnicamente el arma que
contaba cinco balas no se disparó pese a
haber sido gatillada declaró como decía
ese feriado nacional literalmente para
que el pueblo se exprese en paz no y
entre los actos suspendidos pues por
ejemplo los partidos de la Liga de
Fútbol Argentina página 12 dice una
pistola en la cabeza de la Democracia
conmoción nacional por el atentado
contra Cristina kirchner que salvó su
vida porque el disparo no salió y otra
cita distinta del presidente que hizo un
llamado a desterrar los discursos del
odio esparcidos desde diferentes
espacios políticos judiciales y
mediáticos rosa pero vamos ahora a
digamos analizar un poco el contexto
argentino en qué momento se da este
intento de atentado contra la
vicepresidenta una profunda polarización
en la que se enmarca este ataque Rosa
exactamente y así lo describe desde
Buenos Aires marchen tener a para el
país que dice Argentina vivido este
jueves uno de los episodios más funestos
de su democracia reciente y dice que el
intento de magni ha elevado al máximo la
polarización que vive el país que se
incrementó desde que el pasado 22 de
agosto recordemos la fiscalía pidió 12
años de prisión e inhabilitación
permanente para la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández por su presunta
implicación en la causa vialidad Y es
que este contexto tiene mucho que ver en
Cómo se desarrollaron los hechos porque
el atacante se abrió paso entre la
multitud que está congregada en apoyo a
la vicepresidenta recordemos en apoyo
Desde que la fiscalía pidió no está
digamos en causación esta sentencia para
vicepresidenta entonces fue en medio de
esta multitud cuando Cristina Estaba
saludando digamos a sus seguidores que
el atacante se abrió paso y se acercó
pues directamente a escasos centímetros
de la vicepresidenta lo que ha abierto
un enorme debate sobre también el
protocolo de seguridad de la
vicepresidenta recordemos que entre los
cánticos que se escuchan digamos entre
los congregados es si la tocan a
Cristina que quilombo se va a armar Y es
que la propia herramienta vicepresidenta
calificó el montaje la petición de la
Fiscalía de un pelotón de fusilamiento
político mediático permanente todas
estas personas Residencial la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández desde
que se anunció este caso por parte de la
fiscalía una manera de custodiarla no
exactamente y ya solamente para ver un
poco el impacto que ha tenido esto
alrededor del mundo Además de que varios
líderes de la región de América Latina y
el Caribe han expresado su solidaridad y
su apoyo a la vicepresidenta Incluso el
Papa Francisco no También tenemos la
prensa internacional
exactamente Pues por otro lado tenemos
la prensa internacional que reacciona
hasta frente a este intento de asesinato
y para digamos repasar algunos titulares
de Guardian dice intento de asesinato de
la vicepresidenta Argentina
de Argentina víctima de un intento de
asesinato las motivaciones del atacante
permanecen desconocidas el New York
Times da un poco en la clave dice que la
vicepresidenta es la líder más
prominente del país y carta capital dice
de Brasil dice kirchner la líder atacada
en el punto álgido de la polarización
política en Argentina bueno rosa en todo
caso también como dicen por ahí pues no
le tocaba a la vicepresidenta Argentina
Cristina Fernández de verdad y
impactante no como la apuntaron y el
arma dos veces y no funcionó Rosa
Muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información buen fin de semana el
lunes más revista de prensa en directo
América de Francia 24 y de esta manera
llegamos al final del programa por el
día hoy también por esta semana pero en
segundos los espero en un noticiero Aquí
en Francia 24 así que no se despega
[Música]